vision is so natural for humans you just
open your eyes and you understand vision
is it's a very very complicated process
but we don't register most of it
consciously and so it's very hard for us
to realize why is it such a hard problem
for the computer I try to understand how
we can make computers see and understand
our visual world for example if I'm
looking at this redwood tree I'm not
just looking at this tree I'm looking at
it through the prism of what I have seen
before so how do we train computers to
see a lot of the current computer vision
systems are very much about translating
the visual world into a few
keywords which of course is quite
limiting because uh picture is worth a
th000 words so the field of computer
vision today is undergoing a big shift
we were working really hard for many
decades and we had basically nothing to
show for it the problem turned out to be
much deeper and much more exciting than
anyone
imagined when people were starting to
look at artificial intelligence in the
early 60s at MIT they realized that
Vision should be an integral part of the
story have a Rob the robot has some
cameras and the robot is going to sense
its environment and do actions the
vision part of this Grand goal of an AI
robot was considered to be a summer
project the idea was that if you write a
smart enough algorithm you will teach
the computer how to
see only much later did we realize that
what the computer needs is to connect
what it's sensing with what it has seen
in in the
past one of my superpowers that helped
me early on was that my vision is not
great a lot of people I interact with
every day don't know that I have poor
vision I'm able to compensate with good
visual memory I just remember a lot of
things instead of seeing them in a sense
my brain fills in a lot of the missing
details and that was very important for
me early on to realize the huge
importance of large scale visual data
playing in this Enterprise of seeing and
understanding that we're not seeing just
with our eyes we are seeing with our
eyes and our
memory the pattern of bark on a redwood
tree for example the way it looks is
defined by so many different things the
Genome of the tree the weather and it's
impossible to basically write down a
precise formula which would represented
but it is possible to capture a lot of
examples of different trees and
different patterns of bark and that we
can use to model what this bark might
look
like data is absolutely fundamental to
machine learning in general and computer
vision in particular everybody is always
excited about algorithms and actually
it's the data that's doing a lot of the
heavy lifting so one way to think about
about what my lab is doing is to give
data the appreciation it
deserves in our lab we do many different
things connected with visual data scene
understanding image generation and
editing basically modeling the visual
World by creating or modifying it our
work is actually starting to be in the
real world sell driving cars of course
software like ad be Photoshop what we
call computational photography there is
a lot of computer vision that happens
with the latest smartphones from Google
and
apple there are two basic paradigms in
contemporary computer vision the older
and still most prominent Paradigm is
supervised learning it's basically you
get huge amount of images for example or
videos and then for every image some
human is going to go and annotate
what is on that image that supervision
is often something that can introduce
more bias it comes from the
labels and now you have millions of this
labeled images the neural network is
going to try to learn the association
between a particular image and the
corresponding label and some of those
categories are not very
meaningful what we do in our lab is what
we call self-supervised learning we try
to build models that do not require this
linguistic supervision that they can
understand the world from the raw data
itself much like animals are able to
understand the world so for example we
can have an image and then make some
holes in that image and then have the
computer fill in those holes or we can
try to predict in a video what's going
to happen next you get rid of the labels
and so you can get rid of a lot of the
bias that is baked into those
lebs one issue that I have been thinking
for a while we biological agents are
experiencing the world in a continuous
fashion we're going through life
continuously adapting in this kind of
NeverEnding learning Loop for example
you fly into an airport that you have
never been before and yet you're able to
navigate in that airport even if it
maybe looks very different from the
other airpods you're used to for
computers this problem is more extreme
because computers are less able to
generalize in most of the machine
learning algorithms we have a fixed data
set it might be a very big data set you
know billions of images we let the
computer train on all the data in this
data set and then that model is Frozen
it's fixed we go out into the real world
and we just hope somehow we are able to
perform well on this
data one of the projects that we've been
doing in our lab is what we call test
time training which is the idea that
every time you're faced with a new piece
of data a new image for example we use
that image to adapt our model it's
always updating when the environment
changes the model hopefully will change
with it so for example for cell driving
cars a lot of the cell driving cars are
based in California where it rarely
snows almost never and then they go to
Minnesota there needs to be a mechanism
for the car to somehow
adapt right now in our field we are
finding things out all the time the
latest text generative models like Chad
GPT have been very exciting for me I
really should have not been surprised
but I still was very surprised how good
those algorithms were once you give them
enough data huge huge huge amounts of
data give you this almost magical
abilities to generalize to do
analogies a lot of my students have
starting to get interested in robotics
and connection between Robotics and
computer vision they're excited about
this interaction between the data and
the algorithm and trying to figure out
what is happening on the inside it's
kind of like doing Neuroscience on the
computer hopefully that might even give
us some insights into how biological
agents see the
world I think my proudest achievement
has been producing the next generation
of researchers I have had absolutely
wonderful graduate students and post
doogs I feel like this is really my
biggest contribution to
[Music]
science